[Music]
we are a rumor recognizable only as deja
vu and dismissed this is quickly we are
the best kept secret in the universe I
know I want in you erase my parents
memories but you didn't get mine took me
20 years to find you how many people can
say that I found you
which makes me perfect for this job
[Music]
[Music]
you will be with Asian teens I might be
you Karelian scum an FYI your little
club here sucks world's not gonna save
itself I'm driving that really should be
here Joey I thought that we were here we
are
Freddy you go to edge wait are you a
queen indeed she is I pledged loyalty
eternal to you no no I'm not interested
too late I already pledged the loyalty I
wish you'd said no no no before we've
never faced a threat like the hive
they can take the form of anyone I
haven't seen that before even our own
agents do we have a plan
sometimes you have to trust your gut
men and black has been compromised on
trust smell one we protect the earth
that means everyone and everything on
yeah we love a man in black
the men and women in black yeah
perfectly good are you suggesting that
we try the most powerful weapon in the
galaxy for fun do it turn it up a few
excuse me what happened here we have the
best party Kanye showed up and dropped
like a whole new album look around we
got our asses kicked my queen
never serve another I must end my own
life in the most painful way possible I
don't think that she would want you to
you know who are you to know what a
queen would or wouldn't want are you a
queen well I mean to the extent that all
women are yes but no no I'm not a queen
you know what she is though is an agent
that a title it is maybe the best way to
honor the dead is to go on living
yes I pledged loyalty eternal to you
agent Anna no I'm not interested in a
subject too late it's done early pledge
the loyalty I wish you'd said no no no
before and if you should die before I to
end my own life in the most painful way
possible yeah I think what we're looking
at is just press the button to see to
see what was being done
are you suggesting that we try a
weaponized art or fun mm-hmm well for
science I'm fun they don't call it the
empty corner for nothing yes that's why
I made the suggestion go it just bleeds
hero zero what do you think Donald Slope
press the button yep
hmm maybe rattle up a few notches
[Music]
do we think anyone's gonna notice that
that wasn't the devil should we call it
in god no the paperwork is a nightmare
yeah but fungus didn't look too good I
mean he looked good before but no it's
trust me I've seen way worse if this one
time I might be free
[Music]
that's what girl
[Music]
sideview mirror you haven't seen that
before
[Music]
[Music]
always remember the universe has a way
of leading you to where you're supposed
to be at the moment you're supposed to
be there let's do this
it took me 20 years to find you
we can say that
you are the best-kept secret in the
universe and I found you
which makes me perfect for this job
you really think a black suit it's going
to solve all your problems
no but it's damn good on you we
[Music]
recognizable only as DejaVu and
dismissed just as quick a time to prove
yourself agent M we may have a problem
in London welcome to my beat
you will be with Asian Paints one of the
best ever to weather suit catching up on
my daily meditation time for lunch oh
thank you hungry
it's 9:30 Tuesdays taco day we've been
compromised it's every citizen of this
planet at risk
[Applause]
you can all just look right here just
try
gonna be fun left fun with it
there should be a big red button around
here somewhere found it we are the men
in black
looks like the tables of time incredible
[Music]
hop on in a lot of room in the back as
well you're gonna be with James down
here he's doing a survey
my folks woke up to Lexus Sam James
money
[Music]
you weren't supposed to see this I'm
sorry guys I'm gonna need your help
[Applause]
[Music]
we're gonna have to wipe your memory go
ahead guys I'm ready
if you could all just look right here
just try it
men in black 3 the pg-13
recognizable only as deja vu you look
right here
and dismissed just as quickly we are the
best kept secret in the galaxy I want in
20 years ago you erased my parents
memories that you didn't get mine we
don't try out we recruit then I'd like
to be recruited one another truth of the
universe
Souta welcome to the men in black
the men in black goat they'd start I'm
working on it we have a problem in
London
[Music]
hmm welcome to my be move it lady top
dog walking through you will visitation
scoops come on
well it's not going to save itself I'm
driving that really should be here
the hive is a deadly species that can
take the form of anyone even our own
agents I haven't seen that before
we need more firepower he's pointed to
bad guys and pull the trigger as
ramallah men and women
[Music]
sometimes you have to trust your gut
yeah baby Joey I thought that we were
here
step on it would you Freddie you go to H
even though who you're dealing with
you'd protect the earth and everyone and
everything goes
that was awesome we are the men in black
are you suggesting that we try the most
powerful weapon in the galaxy for fun
yeah maybe internal up with you not true
[Music]